hi I'm Hannah I'm the worlds of chaos
mom and I'm here to give you some
moderately helpful advice but stuff you
want to talk about so a few episodes ago
we talked about what it's like to lose
your virginity and the text response was
huge and one text that I kept getting
from all of you girls was about the
topic we're gonna discuss tonight
tonight we're gonna talk about female
masturbation that just sounds awful it's
like a terrible word
you know this is why I have to drink for
this up with it so first is it okay to
masturbate yes it's okay
it's totally fine just do it bye no I'm
just kidding I think a lot of the
questions of is it okay comes from
people having feelings of guilt or
feelings of doubt or being raised with
beliefs that make it seem like it's not
a good thing and I'm not encouraging you
to go against your beliefs if it's
something that makes you feel bad or
something that makes you feel guilty you
don't have to do it
you can totally live without it start a
life or death situation the purpose of
it is to make you feel good so if it
doesn't don't do it but that being said
I feel like there's a double standard
where it's okay for guys to do it and
widely accept it that guys can do it but
for women it's a little bit more
hush-hush like nobody wants to know like
kind of pretend like you don't
I guarantee just as many women do it if
not more definitely more oh my god
you're at sex with a guy you got it do
it next how often ultimately it varies
from person to person there's no
schedule for masturbating it's not like
I have my Wednesday 7:00 p.m. blocked
off like masturbation like no it's just
when the time is right you never know
you could be like alone eating ice cream
watching Forensic Files on a Sunday
night and just feel like all right why
not there's some women do it like as
much as everyday or multiple times a day
some women do it maybe once a month it
just varies based on how much time you
have and how much you need it
so don't feel like there's a certain
amount of times that you should be doing
it or shouldn't be doing it it's
whatever works for you whatever makes
you comfortable and whatever you can
accommodate I okay for me I'm a very
sleepy mom so with Bates so it just
thought everything sleep is
to take priority so it doesn't really
happen that often for me because at the
end of the day I'd rather sleep so next
do women watch porn uh some of them yeah
not all of us it just depends from
person to person and for me personally I
just don't really watch porn especially
heterosexual important because I'm
watching it like Oh first of all that
wieners too big you're doing this for
way too long that can't be comfortable
that's gotta be sore by now you're not
having an orgasm from just a penis
jabbing you like it's just not very
realistic for me but really my opinion
is not the end-all be-all like some
women like it some women don't some
women like other types of porn it's
really a case-by-case basis so do women
watch porn yes should you watch porn I
don't know if you want to for me I get
more out of like a heartfelt text than
watching porn
so next do girls masturbate to dick pics
I feel like typically now if it's a girl
and it's a dick pic from her boyfriend I
feel like maybe they'd be more incentive
to masturbate to it because it's what's
behind the dick that matters but
unwarranted dick pics you can get the
[ __ ] out of here with those nobody has
been a masturbate to that [ __ ] that gets
immediately deleted that's one of the
most offensive things you could possibly
do is like send an unwarranted dick pic
so if you're wondering if like your
boyfriend should send you a dick pic it
really depends on you like do you like
it do you think it looks great great if
so have at it but if a girl hasn't
explicitly asked for it don't send it
that means she don't want it nobody
wants to see that jealous turtle next is
masturbation better than sex for women
masturbation is a solo act party of one
let sex is a totally different
experience that's about connecting with
another person and that's a very
different kind of pleasure for me
there's something just totally magical
about connecting with another person and
like having that love and oh this is a
Fafi sorry having that love and
connection and just like the physical
expression of your love there are great
things to be said about both and as far
as wondering whether one orgasm is
better than the other it really depends
on the time
and place and the headspace urine
masturbation is great but it doesn't
replace sex just like sex doesn't
replace masturbation so if you like one
more than the other that's totally fine
because it's a balance it's just like
whatever works for you it's like
comparing apples to oranges or fingers
to penis and last how do I masturbate
I'm not gonna show you how to do that
this isn't the time or place I'm sorry
but like I'm here for you on a like
advice and support platform but beyond
that I'm not gonna show you how to do it
like try a bunch of different things
like just see what works see what
doesn't work you have the internet you
can figure it out that's all I got for
today I'm Hannah the world's okay it's
mom if there's anything you want me to
talk about in a future episode leave it
in the comments or you can always text
me I don't always respond but I read all
them and I love to know again if there's
a topic you want me to talk about in a
future episode leave it in the comments
or you can text me this is a real number
and I do receive all the texts and I
read them all I don't necessarily
respond to all them because I get a lot
but I love to see what you guys want me
to talk about in the meantime I'm gonna
go take care of some business and buy a
business I mean taking a long nap
till next time
but it is not noise
[Music]